49 seconds of logos over static the
family that plays together hangs
together family moves to a new house
where evil lives Klee shaped laziness
also I realize it interrupts this
close-up shot of box kicking but people
who are moving in or out tend to use the
loading ramp on the truck
ethan hawke isn't talking to Julie Delpy
this entire movie are there no lights in
this house I'm not saying it's
impossible I'm just saying with a blonde
mom and a brown hair dad I don't trust
the red-haired girl I miss my school
here's hoping they saved this film's
originality for something other than the
child is upset about moving dialog your
bad theory have to kill her go free you
ruin people's lives
reading ruins people's lives I'm gonna
go out on a limb and do do you know what
happened to the last family here
too soon we didn't move in a few houses
down from the crime scene again what
wife doesn't know exactly what house
they're moving into also you know your
husband better than you know yourself
you know damn well he moved into the
murder house I didn't move in a few
houses down from the crime scene again
did we we didn't also dude she's
obviously gonna find out eventually that
you moved into the actual crime scene
house so how do you hope to get away
with this lie I mean it's bad enough the
movies trying to get away with it signs
that your house is haunted you move to
Pennsylvania and encounter a scorpion
Alison is a dick to Pennsylvania
scorpions things are going so badly for
Alison that he can only afford to turn
on one light in the dining room that
barely lights the table okay so far this
movies a lot like eight millimeter and
that is really not a good thing I would
reel-to-reel home movies however evil be
this heavily edited Ellison is basically
doing cinemasins here the sins of murder
audience sees a shadow pass behind the
protagonist while their back is turned
cliche and that shadow turns out to be
something harmless red herring cliche
yep still basically eight millimeter
here
wait they just moved in today and you're
telling me he's gone to the trouble of
plugging in and wiring up all the vanity
lights and his precious office shelves
even though they're empty or is it
possible this just seemed like a cool
shot to the director
King County police please who dials the
operator to get the police
what is this Mayberry didn't he say it
was an emergency
how did Ellison get caught up in the how
can I direct your call web of horrors
damn calling the cops here is like
trying to call your cable company they
can still trace that call I think but
maybe we missed the part where he set up
the call to be bounced off multiple
satellites this is the modern horror
movie model hire a bigger name actor
than horror movies usually good like
Ethan Hawke or Vera Farmiga then just do
all the same Boogedy bullet horror
movies have been doing for decades and
hope the audience is so distracted by
the big-name actor they don't care step
put your kid in a box step 2 cut a hole
in that box
it had an adventure day one was nine
tears yeah one of those night terrors
that cost you to climb into a box and
pop out in the creepiest way imaginable
also oh look
no worries everyone just another red
herring their son has a medical freakout
condition that was previously
undisclosed by the movie which is a
cheap self-absorbed parents don't notice
their son make a bacon and mayonnaise
sandwich for breakfast have a nice
morning with your medicine oh come on
this wife is already established as not
wanting the husband's job to affect her
kids she would not casually joke about
murder victims in front of them so
eight-millimeter then it's a reboot I'm
guessing but thirty minutes in not sure
what the difference is except no Joaquin
Phoenix as someone who regularly ran
projectors in his life I can tell you
that pausing a film like this would
cause an immediate burning of film not
the super delayed let's all have a good
look at the evil that this projector
allows discount The Crow as a former
projectionists all I can say is haha you
are fired raging fire can be put out by
simply blowing on it I know you're in
Pennsylvania so why does Google think
you're in someplace New York also
totally obvious book that fake Google
results are totally obviously both good
and fake survey from this released in
1966 uh the text in the search result
that he clicked said 1965 okay so all
the families we seen get killed so far
were either in a location or doing
something that connected to their deaths
in some way what's this family doing
that involved beds director puts the
true horror in the reflection of the
protagonist glasses so we don't have to
see it head-on and so the idiots at the
MPAA will consider it less violent this
guy drinks every time he sees something
he doesn't like on screen if we took
that approach we'd be dead faster than
Nicolas Cage in leaving Las Vegas
there's your local news getting it wrong
again their throats were slit right
that's not stabbing unless
nice way to describe throat-slitting man
these days I'm gonna need more than a
few addict creeks to take your horror
movie seriously why is there so much
damn light outside Oh looks like he's
bringing a knife to a ghost fight
another problem with modern horns that
the audience is completely clueless
which noises the character can hear and
which ones are just on the soundtrack to
boost the creepiness factor signs that
your house is haunted you move to
Pennsylvania and encounter a coral snake
also Gyo movie red herring me once shame
on me red herring me three times in 42
minutes you in the ear we interrupt this
horror movie to bring you the money pit
this is one FBI profilers office this is
my private office I'm serious then why
did you lead him in here the guy asked
for an autographed book
you didn't say wait here while I go get
it you know it's really spooky mr.
boogie doesn't show up in any of the
earlier showings of this film
Ellison got a hold of the director's cut
somewhere mr. boogie is a huge Harry
Potter fan I gotta admit that is creepy
but there's no way Ellison shot this
footage holding his iPhone the way he
was mr. boogie I'm wondering did the
other families encounter mr. boogie
being a prankster dick before he killed
them did someone in the household watch
these home movies just like Ellison is
doing now this dude should be running
for his life maybe grabbing his wife and
kids on the way out but definitely not
going to the office to investigate
further possible those killer better
grab a baseball bat horror movie
character leaves their door wide open
when they go outside at night to
investigate something cliche Trevor
you can rascal come everyone it's a
beautiful night to come out and be
creepy for no reason
I had a few of the pertinent files
pulled for you and had them fax over
because I had to call you from my home
line unless the sheriff find out I'm
helping you but faxes to the office
regarding the matter are a-okay obsessed
crime Ryder somehow hasn't watched this
film yet and a full 10% of this movie is
glamour shots of super 8 projectors
being threaded and powered up this is
definitely the biggest scare of the
movie but the super loud jump scare
noise is yet another major cheat you
mean he's been watching lawn work with
the door open they all revolve around
him meeting the souls of human children
to survive that one child every decade
or so will do and he has to kill the
entire rest of the family for some
reason including other tasty children he
could simply store the fridge for later
most want to scare unseen audience but
not main character of the film Ellison
hears a noise but decides not to look
anywhere in the direction that that
noise came from aa editing ghost girl
who can appear out of thin air
apparently needs to run away before
Ellis and Caesar as opposed to just
disappearing the way she appeared and
these kids are assholes what is the
point of this also these kids happen to
find a creek in the floor everywhere
they run while Alison walks through the
house without finding one weak spot what
a bitch why is it so bright outside
does she know whose house this is was
locked so Ashley's getting scolded for
drawing a picture outside of her room
but meanwhile this picture inside her
room somehow goes unnoticed I wanna
paint a picture
but Ashley plays the pronoun game so
that her parents have to ask what the
hell she and her being she's doing here
she's the one day he's reading his book
about tricks he finds out about this
right after Alison was asked if she knew
about this did you think I wouldn't find
out good point but for a while there
yeah we were beginning to think that I
don't even want to think about what that
sweater smells like he hasn't taken it
off the entire movie Ellison just
happens to be watching an old interview
that serves as his apology so that his
wife can walk by and realize man I
really shouldn't have been so mad at
this guy for moving us into a murder
house what a bitch
Alison has no peripheral vision no one
in the entire house here is this fit and
no one in the entire house here's this
kid either important phone call is
neglected because Ellison is moving on
which makes sense but couldn't you at
least answer it to tell the deputy and
moving on and he could give you the
crucial warning that you desperately
need Vincent D'Onofrio isn't stupid
enough to even let himself be credited
on this and why doesn't the deputy leave
a message anyway if it's important and
you can't get the guy on the phone at
least leave a message damn this demon is
an amazing film buff isn't he also
that's how they get you
you don't appreciate a film at first but
then the director steps in and says try
this version the studio butchered the
original what's with the shushing don't
tell anybody about this random person
who's gonna die anyway
Thanks what happens if a couple without
kids moves into the murder house are
they left alone so this is the child who
tells Michael Bay what to do I still
don't know for sure if I'm dealing with
the supernatural or not but I do know
for sure an eight year old girl can't do
all this subduing and duct-taping an
adult body moving in she why are the
demon ghosts kids running again
it's mr. boogie going to extra kill them
if they stay in the picture movie goes
full take on me at the ending cue
seriously
oh and just one more thing
Oh what's in the box can you give me
what's enough your box
yo kiddo taco Ben yes where I thought I
was out they pull me back in listen mr.
marbles Marge Simpson sold her first
house the manor house I just wanna get
my bad captain my captain
yo kick some man-sized hit you took dog
was the last time you smoked weed
so what what um 12th grade oh we were
smoking week yeah well that was a little
barbecue in the yard you see the flames
for miles
well then surrounded like wild Injuns